[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
thank you
he was woke before woke with Google
yesterday
in true Trump style he said he didn't
like the word woke and then used it over
and over and over to describe her
military
oh my God and this is the story so
here's the thing Joe Biden trips over a
sandbag everything's cool everything's
fine the right is like impeach him now
get rid of him
he has to go he turned around there was
a sandbag in his waney trip like any
other person would
like like a 10 year old would trip and
fall over a sandbag
it's not rocket science I mean a lot of
people are blaming on the Secret Service
which I I don't know I think I mean it's
kind of bogus too the sandbag looked
like it was holding down a teleprompter
to me on the stage so it didn't fall
over and hit him so I mean he tripped he
fell it happens you ever [__] fall
I'm almost broke my ankle walking down a
set of steps and I'm in my 30s
and they have like a [__] cast on and
[__] for a while
it happens but he got up and then he was
dancing around back at the White House
oh [__]
but you know that's how the [__] goes
it's how it goes that's how the internet
works one little thing and oh my God
we need to get rid of him and then this
morning
the jobs numbers drop and Fox News oh
man they're having a terrible time
trying to explain to Their audience why
job growth is bad for the economy
all right well the stock market's up
dead ceilings raced and the job numbers
are great this is horrible for the
economy
oh man I'm sorry this is going to be a
great summer folks
a fantastic summer this is going to be
think about it
think about think about the summer we're
in for here nothing but mocking Donald
Trump Ron DeSantis Mike Pence Chris
Christie
and people who think that Joe Biden
tripping on a sandbag is the end of his
presidency
this is great and then last night on
Twitter did you see this
did you did okay
and we're going to talk about this a lot
today I'm sure
because we got uh Matt Walsh on the
bonehead of the weak Pole right
I'm sure Elon will make his way into the
conversation somewhere last night
um Matt Walsh he doesn't know what a
woman is he has no clue he doesn't know
he even made a movie about it he didn't
know neither does his audience they have
no idea what a woman is either
I don't know why it's 2023 it's really
easy to look this [__] up you can go man
look you can go on the internet and find
out here's what a woman is
it's a gender that people identify as
that's what a woman is it's not
complicated it's not hard just because
you get confused when you see a trans
woman and you get a little Chub that
that doesn't mean she's not a woman and
it doesn't make you gay but I can
understand your confusion
and I understand because you hate gay
people you know yourself hate that you
have then you really you know I get it I
I kind of well I don't really get it but
you know it's understandable
coming from you know your Nazi
standpoint right I get it Nazis you're
gonna Nazi that's just how it's gonna be
the last night on Twitter Matt Walsh and
the daily wire were trying hard to make
us believe that their V their movie was
being censored that's I I think that's
all it's all [__] it's all it was
all [__] theater folks all of it
all of it on Twitter last night it was
all theater they knew no one would pay
attention to this [__] thing no one
gives a [__] about this movie no one
gives a [__]
so much so that they have to give it
away for free on a free platform
and the only way to get anyone to pay
attention to it is to act like it's
being censored
and then and then after it's censored
from elon's Twitter right it's elon's
Twitter Elon can just go in and make a
phone call and the [__] can fix
it
after all the theater of how it's being
censored it's the left's fault
get the [__] out what do you mean the
lunch it's not the less fault that you
make shitty movies what do you want from
us you make shitty documentaries that
are full of just [__] lies and
[__]
what do you want from us it's not our
fault you make shitty movies and no one
wants to see the piece of [__] if anyone
wanted to see the [__] they'd
pay 19.99 to go rent the son of a [__]
or they pay eight bucks to go to the
[__] movie theater and if you
wouldn't make such a bigoted ass movie
anyways maybe people would play it
you're just offended you're just
offended that no one wants to watch or
see your [__] movie and no one will
play it but they'll play Little Mermaid
and it'll sell gazillions of dollars
worth of tickets worldwide that's what
you're pissed off about Matt Walsh and
daily wire and Ben Shapiro and it's all
[__] again the whole thing I believe
my personal opinion looking at this the
whole thing was all [__] they
planned this censorship they plan this
outrage to get people to see this video
to pump the views which by the way I'm
gonna show you proof that that's not
getting the views that they say they're
getting not even [__] close and that
is why I think they did this because
Elon has changed on Twitter how you see
views now if you don't know what this is
Matt Walsh you watched us play videos
before Matt Walsh and you watched us
play clips from this [__] bigoted ass
movie where they go around and they they
demonize and dehumanize an entire group
of people
trans women specifically because they're
terrified that they'll find a trans
woman attractive and it'll give them a
boner and they think that makes them gay
that's the entire premise of the entire
movie their entire movement
this the entirety of this in-cell
transphobic movement is that they just
may want to suck someone's dick that's
the entirety of it it's [__] insane
it's crazy guys listen look if you want
to pick up a chick and she's got a dick
and you want to suck it it's not that
big of a deal we don't care go for it
more power to you find some love out
there wherever you can wherever you can
and if you find love having it in your
mouth fine great we don't give a [__]
We're Not Gonna judge you what don't you
understand about that we're not gonna
March you off to the gas Chambers that's
what you're calling for
welcome you into our coalition
for crying out loud Jesus Christ stop
[__] being so goddamn insensitive
stop being so fragile and insecure about
your sexuality it's okay we we're all
secure over here that's why we don't
have problems being allies or being
openly gay or what whatever sexuality
you identify as but just because you
have a certain group you identify with
doesn't make you a demon
I mean unless you're a Nazi oh boy that
really I mean come on
self-identifying as a Nazi and they're
doing it
um apparently rage against machine uh
posted some anti-nazi post and people
are really upset that they're anti-nazi
like Nazis are upset see here's how it
works we're upset that you [__]
people want to eliminate an entire group
of people starting and you you use trans
children as your as your tagline in but
you want to exterminate a whole group of
people the lgbtq community and we're a
little [__] upset and the reason why
is because you're taking away [__]
people's Liberty
the child works but you're upset that
someone's posting anti-nazi things hmm I
wonder I wonder who who would be upset
that someone's posting anti-nazi stuff I
don't know maybe you could figure it out
this race with Rhonda santis and Donald
Trump
is getting really boring
look fellas you need to heat this up a
bit right I mean if we can do some
political theater here that would be
great like last night with with daily
wire Matt Walsh Ben shapir and Elon Musk
they did political theater on Twitter to
make people think something was being
censored when it really what wasn't it
was all [__]
but but look fellas Ronnie Donny come on
come on come on
you gotta you gotta do something better
than this this is ridiculous Trump goes
out he he works a crowd to try to see if
they hate the word woke right in Iowa
he's like oh I don't like the word woke
woke is a bad word I hate when they they
don't even know what it means I'm gonna
show you the clips
and then later that night on Hannity
Show which it's not a message to Iowa
that's what you got to remember about
this okay now we're gonna pay attention
to it because we pay attention to
everything right we see everything and
we compare it to everything else
most people in Iowa don't give a [__]
right they're not gonna compare this to
what he said that next night on Sean
Hannity or will they I don't know who
knows but the rest of America isn't
going to Sean Hannity didn't play the
clip of him saying woke is a bad word
hours before to people in Iowa
and then he called our military woke
right this is so this is come on you Don
Donnie Ronnie you guys can do way better
than this this is boring as [__] man we
want this summer to be [__]
flamethrowers we want you to destroy
each other's political careers we want
your supporters to rapidly fight each
other here online and in real life for
that matter [__] I love to see a Nazi
punch in a Nazi that'd be fantastic I
love when they punch themselves in the
face that's great
that's great
but you're this this you're boring as
[__] man last night Rhonda Santos
apparently ate a booger on stage while
his wife was calling him the governor
why he stood there with no emotion at
all like when she was trying to tell
stories about his children and she was
trying to tell jokes I mean they weren't
that great
I mean obviously some right winger wrote
him for her so it wasn't that [__]
funny but he couldn't even pop a smile
he ate some boogers though I'm not
kidding he wipes a snot from his nose
and just wipes that some [__] all the
way down in this bottom lip
I mean I'll show you I'm gonna show you
the clip and it's slow-mo zoomed in he
totally does it I mean you know I you
know I get an inch on my nose every once
in a while here on the show I get a bug
hanging you know it's we're humans we
get boogers right
boogers are a human thing it's not that
big of a deal Ronnie but most people
don't [__] slide it down into their
bottom lip like a like stew in tobacco I
mean God damn
Jesus
uh some people are asking about the up
wire link
um listen the up wire is not I don't I
don't know what happened this morning
but I'm not able to uh I'm not able to
to uh stream to the up wire this morning
uh something happened here let me check
it out while we're talking about it so I
I don't I don't think I'm gonna be able
to stream to the up wire so anyone on
the upward they must have [__] who
knows they might have banned something
yep
um
[Laughter]
let's see they're they're banning
they're they're they're banning them
for a week which one is it oh it's it's
something I I don't know I don't know
we'll we'll see we'll see there's a
there's a strike on the account so it
must have been some right-wing troll
reporting some [__]
and sat normally goes that's how it
normally goes so we aren't going to be
able to stream on the up wire for a
little bit until we get that result so
um if you normally watch on the up wire
come on over to the uh to the Tony
Michaels Channel and you'll be able to
see it
yeah there's no live link on up wire
because and we we streamed up our you
know what why why we're saying that go
to upwired.com go to the upward.com or
on YouTube just search the up wire and
go subscribe over there show them what
the [__] we're made of show them that we
don't want to be censored we don't want
to be censored like Matt Walsh
and elon's fake censorship last night
ah YouTube [__] hates me they [__]
hate me
it's because I say the f word a lot and
I say crazy [__] into a microphone and
they don't like the truth
at least the way I deliver it you know
what I mean they don't
you just don't like truth real and wrong
I want it scripted they want a boring
that's all I wanted I guess that's what
the algorithm wants [__] I don't know I
just do what I do here
and um it's time I'm running it oh boy
it's Friday we got bone end of the week
did you know that bonehead of the week
bone end of the week nah it's gonna be a
good Friday did you know uh Margaret
Taylor Greene was on our bonehead of the
weak Bowl
and sheep May
I don't know we're gonna find out if
she's still undefeated
I don't know I don't know
um
Allison says we like it the way way it
is John yeah [__] yeah Allison on
YouTube hell yeah we like it the way it
is you like the f word oh by the way
speaking of [__] him let me show you I
got um
uh we're gonna put more products on here
uh later on but I I posted this here
um I know I usually don't show screen
shares during the first 30 minutes but
hell it's Friday why not I said for all
those out there who know what a woman is
Now's the Time to grab a fanny pack to
carry around your antifa membership card
that's right we got [__] them fanny
packs we talked about it yesterday I put
them up there this morning so you can go
get your um [__] em fanny packs just go
to the Tony michaels.com
more importantly I want to show you I
changed there you go see that I changed
the AV the Avi I like that [__] logo
so much but I think it needs a dark
background don't you don't you think it
needs like a black background instead of
white
I'm rethinking this hmm I think maybe we
should do this live on air maybe I don't
know
um change the change it a bit I'm just
saying I don't know I don't I think
should I do that should I change it to
Black hmm
maybe I should uh let's see there we go
okay share Let's uh
I just want to change this to where it's
black instead of white it just looks
better probably right
I think it does
I I need a background what the hell does
that mean
I need a background for what
for here it is a background
it looks just black but
um
it's going with The Branding the black
branding that's all I'm saying
what are you gonna do uh let's get this
this pride thing going here on the um
on the on my Twitter that's the only
place I put it so far I mean you know
now let's see
let's get it up there
oh what the hell that's not what I want
that was crazy
that was crazy okay so we're going to uh
put this up on the Twitter account here
and we'll uh
oh well [__] I'm not even
hmm what do you mean by I need a
background
we got a background it's not completely
black
it shows
out with yeah yeah you're right Brian it
does show better uh when it is it is
black
let's see edit profile let's go edit
this and let's select that one
and I think we'll do this here now a
little bit Yeah okay good save all right
now let's let's see if you guys like the
the new version as opposed to the old
one here here's here it is in Black what
do you guys think does it look better in
Black
I don't know I think it does
I think it looks better in Black I'm
gonna I'm gonna leave it like that
um for pride month I think and maybe
pass that [__] it
If Everyone likes it you know I I've
always left that stupid um
me with the sunglasses and the backwards
hat I've always left that on there I
don't know I think it's I think it's
everyone makes fun of the picture but
I'm like wow what
I mean I think it's I think it's all
right
but I I always left it up there because
I didn't know if I changed it or someone
know who the hell it was you know what I
mean
uh black looks better they're saying
yeah okay good good uh everyone agrees
Black's better it just stands out more
the here look the the logo stands out
more the [__] em logo and it's the it's
the pride colors Gabe Sanchez put this
uh Pride [__] logo together
um is who did that you can give all the
credit to Gabe Sanchez
and we can give the credit um for the
idea uh uh to to
um to the audience here and I believe it
uh
who who originally
it was um
gosh dang it who was it
that it was Lady lib right that gave us
the uh the idea
um
yeah we got a one-week ban on up wire
anyone out there on that usually watches
on up wire if you're not watching on up
wire right now it's because they got a
band we're gonna look into it we're
gonna figure that out they hate us
YouTube hates us YouTube hates me uh why
speaking of that because they hate us
make sure to subscribe yes it was Miss
love seek Miss loveseek is the one who
who suggested it thank you Miss loveseek
um for the pride logo and we'll get um I
think she was messaging me this morning
we'll get some women's
um fitted maybe some tank tops and some
fitted tees on the store I'll get more
products we'll do a sticker and we'll do
some other stuff uh for the for the
pride [__] them and then I'll put some
more of the uh let them eat rake uh
merch up here's the let me let them eat
rake uh shirt let Demi rake store not be
Tony michaels.com make sure make sure
you are subscribing to the YouTube
channel here on the Tony Michaels
podcast but make sure you go over to the
up bar too now that we're having a
little bit of trouble to uh stream over
there so the upwire.com and you know the
YouTube channel or you just type in the
up wire and it'll bring you to the
channel Also let's check in on Twitch
let's see what we got going over there
oh man look at that you guys are kicking
ass over on Twitch
all right follow us on Twitch it's free
to follow us on Twitch too so if you
normally watch this on the up wire maybe
you can go check us out on Twitch
twitch.tv Tony Michaels that's twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels you can go check
us out over there on Twitch it's free to
follow us on Twitch so do that and then
if you want to subscribe and you want to
give us a subscription for free if you
have an Amazon Prime account you can do
that just go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com and you
follow the directions it's like the
fourth tab down our moderator Mighty
librarian gave you directions on how to
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account and give us that one free
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account
and that you know
that'll help out and help us out the
show uh Shadow woman seven gifting some
monthly subscriptions out there thank
you very much on Twitch
she's always kicking ass over there got
a few more follows this morning so thank
you very much for all the support on
Twitch it means a lot that we get the
support that we get from you guys on all
these platforms
I mean I I stream to all of them
sometimes it's overwhelming like hey you
know what I mean I am posted on
Instagram in a long time because it's
just it's just too I listen I do two
hours of a live show every day we want
to do three right so I talk three hours
a day to you guys every single weekday
um and and it's it's a lot of prep it's
a lot of prep afterwards uh to get it
going and I'm I'm so glad that you guys
come and you listen from front to back
that's my goal
is just for everyone to come listen uh
to the show for two and eventually three
hours a day that's what I want that's
what I want you just to listen ah and
doing Clips every day and really trying
to force it out there on social media I
feel like it's forced kind of like last
night when Matt Walsh and the daily wire
was trying to convince us that they were
being censored by the left even though
Elon Musk runs and owns Twitter he can
do whatever he wants
like he can literally do whatever he
wants and he did he tweeted the [__]
movie
he tweeted the [__] movie Elon did
nice they're claiming that it's got like
25 million views it doesn't have 25
million views I'm gonna show you the
[__] evidence it doesn't have 25
million views that's all a bunch of
[__] it just is no [__] way and
the reason why I know this is because I
still have on my iPhone I still have the
old Twitter without the up without the
new update
where it has the impression count so the
new Twitter has impression count
they got rid of the actual video view
count on the new app why I still got the
old version so I can see the video count
in the Analytics
and it's not even close
to 20. it's not even close to [__] 10
million let alone [__] 25 million
this was all in an effort to [__]
trick people into thinking people are
actually watching this stupid thing no
one's watching this piece of garbage
nobody that's the reason why they have
to give it away for free these people
are free market capitalist right that's
what they claim ah the free market the
free market they want a [__] ban and
boycott everything that has a goddamn
Rainbow on it which is not free market
it's not free speech you [__]
lunatics
they want to ban drag shows drag
readings which are free speech and
they're bitching about free speech on
Twitter
the [__] out of here man people lost
your minds you people are brain dead and
sell [__] God damn were you
whiny little [__] Karen's bitching
that your video didn't get played on
Twitter do you know how many times I
post a video and the algorithm doesn't
pick it up it won't even show it to
[__] 200 of my followers and I got
almost 35 000 followers on Twitter and
the name shown 200 of them what do you
want I don't [__] start texting Elon
hey man why are you censoring my video
what
why aren't why in the algorithm picking
up my video
you [__] [__]
get over it God damn I you know what
Hitler would be [__] disappointed in
you nincompoop Nazis completely [__]
disappointed Jesus Christ you weak
cowardly little [__] God damn
I wish they were a worthy opponent
really don't you
these right Wingers
God
they're so pathetic
and it's so I mean God damn it sometimes
it's tough to get on here and Bash them
for two hours
because it's not it's sometimes it's not
even worth it like this stupid woke
thing Trump did yesterday like really
man this is the [__] ah man
this is the lead story that this guy
says you shouldn't use the word woke and
then he continues that night to use the
word woke because he obviously had a bad
reception to it when he said it out loud
and he and he has to double down on it
later on
and he does it so we'll [__] Yap
about it and we'll mock him I mean he
doesn't want to be mocked but we are
going to mock him for [__] sure you
know that here at the Tony Michaels
podcast oh my God
whew all right it's Friday bone end of
the week coming up at the top of the
hour you know what we do you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez break
it down every single Friday every single
Friday so don't forget to subscribe here
on YouTube you're not going to want to
miss it that's where you vote for bone
end of the week in the community tab you
also can vote on elon's Twitter as long
as Matt Walsh and crying and whining
just go to at Tony Michael's pod and you
can vote there also download every
single episode on Apple Spotify and
Google and if you're used to watching on
the up wire today you're not going to
watch because we're banned we're banned
we're actually censored we're actually
censored on the on the up bars Channel
now but you can watch on Facebook if you
still have a Facebook account and go to
at the Tony Michaels that's at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook you can watch there
or again you can follow us for free on
Twitch
and watches on Twitch there and get in
the chat with the twitch with the
twitchers is that what you call them the
twitchers I don't know you know we got
we got four really big chats
we have the upward chat we got the
YouTube chat right here and then we've
got the Facebook Chat every day and then
we've got the twitch chat so you can
like go back and forth back and forth
some people are in both chats are and
two chats at a time chatting with
everyone and I wish there was a way for
like this to put it all in one [__]
bucket so you all could talk to each
other across platforms but they're not
gonna do that no [__] way will they
do that and you better not you better
not go anywhere because we'll be right
back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
well it was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
years Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
the Looney Tunes are [__] all over
bigots this morning
oh it's hilarious I don't know who runs
this Looney Tunes account I don't can't
tell I don't know if it's verified I
don't know I'm gonna ask Gabe Sanchez
what he thinks and when he gets on the
show about this Looney Tunes account and
here let me let me show you this um
Looney Tunes post from this Looney Tunes
account this is um
and it says happy pride get your drag on
and of course it's Bugs Bunny and
several uh in cases in in the actual
show The Looney Tunes where he dresses
up and drag you know these people think
the drag was just invented
and here's Bugs Bunny been doing it for
years in the cartoon and Looney Tunes
pointing it out this morning
with it
in true fashion I think this is a great
piece of art I actually I actually this
would be great to [__] print and
frame on the wall
I think it's pretty cool right I like it
I like it yesterday uh was uh you know
the start of pride
month and we were outside yesterday
having some birthday cake on the back
patio
it's covered patio and it started
pouring ass rain I mean just porn ass
rain and there's a rainbow in this guy
and I was like God damn
ah they're gonna be they're gonna be
boycotting clouds and [__] boy cotton
Barber how can you have a barbecue out
here when there's rainbows in the sky
this pride month is killing me it's
killing my sensitivity so thank you
Looney Tunes for um
for giving us uh
the uh the The Pride Bugs Bunny drag
it's fantastic
um again
so yesterday and I don't know if you if
you heard about this
but the daily wire is really shitty at
movies like they've tried to make sammer
movies and they [__] suck no one
watches them
so they decided because no one's
watching their movie and paying to watch
their movie then what they would do
is that they would just they would just
put it on Twitter for free that way they
could try to make people think people
were watching it
so they had to have a strategy here
right they didn't have a strategy to
make people think that people were
actually watching it people are saying
people are saying oh people are saying
and uh
it it wasn't gonna go the way they
wanted right meaning
if they just posted it no one was gonna
watch that trash no one was even gonna
pay attention to that trash
so what they had to do I believe this is
my belief watching this whole thing back
and forth and I think Gabe um me and him
were messaging about it last night we're
actually in a in a room a mar one of
Mario's rooms and Gabe was on stage I
was actually listening but it was that
[__] Vivek guy he wouldn't shut the
[__] up I don't know who's paying this
guy to run
um and Gabe asked him that question
who's paying you to run
for president and he kind of laughed
he's like
that's that's a really that's a really
dumb question
uh who's paying me to run oh well I'm
self-funded yeah okay
right right so funded with all that
Saudi money
to make sure that you now make sure you
make way for Trump because this guy this
was that guy man he really goes hard
after other um
candidates but he's really like gloved
with Trump
I wonder why it's almost like he's a
plant
from the Saudis
for Trump
I don't know it just feels like I just
get that [__] feeling
and they were calling this guy out this
Vivek guy I don't mean to go on a
tangent here they're calling him out
being a Soros fellow
I'm not sure exactly what that is I
don't know I don't get the Soros checks
that they say that he sends out so I
don't know what a Soros fellow is but
apparently he tried to he tried to get
that scrubbed of his Wikipedia page this
Vivek guy who's running against Donald
Trump in the Republican primary running
against him okay yeah Vivek okay yeah
gotcha
yeah I bet I bet people aren't paying
you to make sure that you're actually
Trump's little
go to opponent
um well I'm just just I'm just
speculating what what do you want from
me look Grandpa poopy pants it's found
out that the [__] got [__]
tapes of him talking about how he had
classified documents
that that planned attacks on Iran
and and Jared Kushner ends up with two
billion dollars of Saudi money in his
lap and Donald Trump ends up with all
these big huge gazillion dollar golf
tournaments at his [__] golf courses
that they couldn't even sell tickets to
did you know that they couldn't even
sell a [__] tickets they were giving
them away
they were basically paying people to
come watch this golf tournament because
golf people didn't want this [__]
thing the PGA is where it's at not the
live tournament they didn't want a
[__] capitulate to Bone Saul and the
Saudis because Donald Trump passed them
information about the plans to attack
Iran yes I'm saying that's my
take on what is happening I mean you
look at it what else are you supposed to
think
are we supposed to believe that Jared
Kushner received two billion dollars and
Donald Trump received golf golf matches
at his golf courses which God knows how
much they paid to have those things
things there
for for they paid for the golf matches
to be at his golf Journey yeah okay yeah
right they couldn't sell tickets to it
they even had Nelly come up and and
perform and they still couldn't sell
tickets
are you listening to what I'm telling
you
it's all [__] it's all [__] he
stole those [__] documents to sell
them or to trade them
for something that gained him money
because he's [__] broke
he's been broke for a long time
a long time this guy's been broke
because everything Trump touches turns
the liquid [__]
absolutely everything that's why the
Republican parties and such shambles why
do you think Kevin McCarthy and the
Republicans got [__] had by the guy
who tripped over a sandbag
okay here's the thing listen up
[__]
if it's so bad that Joe Biden tripped
over a sandbag you got schooled by that
[__] in this debt ceiling deal
you got [__] roasted
by the guy who can't even match a
sandbag do the math on that one Micah
you [__] boneheads
and it's all because of trump
who do you think directed Kevin McCarthy
to do what he did to directed Marjorie
Taylor green to do what she did
who who wanted the [__] economy to
crash so that he could be like see Joe
Biden crashed the economy and then this
morning
then this morning on Fox News like I
said earlier they're trying to figure
out how to make job numbers going up bad
the stock market's like whoa that's cool
everyone in the country is like whoa
that's cool oh man job numbers up and
they beat expectations listen to this
they beat expectations 14 out of 17
months so in other words they were
projecting a certain amount of jobs and
Joe Biden's America Joe Biden's economy
out did those projections the last in
the last 17 months 14 times 14 times now
I'm not saying the economy's perfect
because the economy is definitely not
perfect for everyone I mean Jesus Christ
the [__] Trump tax cuts are still in
place
people are still mired with [__] with
[__] health care costs grocery costs
gas costs because their wages are down
and their wages are stagnant
so yeah we got a long ways to go before
[__] middle middle income and Middle
America and and average Americans get
ahead in the economy I'm not gonna
disagree with that
but [__] like down in Florida where
they're preventing migrants from working
is only going to hurt their economy
and it's going to hurt the national
economy it's going to have effect on
inflation for farming products if you
aren't aware
so if we could get these [__] Nazis
out of the way and out of our [__]
government maybe serious people could
set serious policy and we could ramp up
and rev up the engine of the economy and
give them middle average working class
American the actual [__] keys to the
car
not [__] sludge like Kevin McCarthy
Marjorie Taylor green and Donald Trump
[__] out of here or Rhonda santis for
crying out loud
everyone thinks that Rhonda Santos would
be better than Trump what the [__] are
you talking about Rhonda Santos has
ruined Florida
he's ruined his [__] political career
if you want to know the honest truth I
told the [__] I've been saying
Ron Ron just wait your turn dude wait
till 2028 you won't be Governor anymore
you can run and you won't kill your
[__] political career you won't do it
but then he he can't [__] help
himself
he got too full of himself these [__]
fascists get too excited about their
power
and about their influence they get way
too exciting they get way out in front
of their [__] skis which is fine by
me hey whatever you want to do face
plant buddy go for it good eat your
boogers on stage while your wife's
talking about how you [__] feed your
toddler's cake at two o'clock in the
morning
what do you want from me I don't make
this [__] up I just [__] come here to
comment on it I don't get to make this
[__] up
I don't get to make this [__] up I just
I gotta [__] come here and talk about
it get it out of my system so you guys
can get some cathartic release too for
two hours a day where the hell is Gabe
Sanchez I'm just kidding he should be
here any minute now he should be here
any minute any minute let's see if he's
got the bonehead of the week uh assets
going on here uh that's right he does
all the bonehead of the week bone net of
the week we're gonna do bone end of the
week here in just about 20 minutes we're
gonna get it out there
um I was really surprised when we put
the bone into the weak pole last night
when somebody reminded us you know who
you are uh when when a few people
reminded us that hey dummies hey you
boneheads bone of the weak pool
um we had to get that going
and um
it uh let's see yeah there we go
so anyways
uh it gave Gabe was like well what about
these three and we he decided he decided
kind of who he's gonna put up one of
them was Marjorie Taylor green
I'm like oh man well
that's how that's gonna go uh because
she's undefeated but there may be a
surprise this week I don't know maybe
maybe just maybe there'll be a surprise
this week it's hard to tell
um did you guys
foreign
let's see
I'm trying to do two three four things
at once oh yeah here's here's the one
thing I wanted to show you from earlier
so um
they're they're they're really mad that
Tom Morello from Rage Against machine
here's Wu-Tang for children's uh post
here uh he's he's posting the New York
Post
he says hold up being anti-nazi is is
bad now uh rage against machines Tom
Morello ripped for anti-nazi post what
what are you talking about
of course
um of course Nazis think anti-nazi posts
are bad why wouldn't they
right I mean it makes sense
that Nazis would believe that anti-nazis
not Nazi posts are bad
it's really weird well we live in a
weird timeline though
um
oh
[Laughter]
okay so he oh he's gonna be on at ten I
think he said in ten
oh oh acting not in 10.
I got you okay
so we're gonna get Gabe Sanchez here in
about 20 minutes
I've got the assets ready
he's got him he's got the assets ready
ready to go for bonehead of the week so
be able to get in the bonehead as soon
as we get there but let's let's go to uh
let's go to some clips here let me see
if I can find uh some of these clips
that you want to see is there anything
new out there what
what do we got I I'm sorry it's Friday
what do you want from me
oh because we're gonna go run through
the tick tock of last night with Matt
Walsh the daily wire and Elon Musk again
I think it was all made up
I think it was
I mean maybe I'm [__] wrong but I
think it was all [__] made up
just to pump these views here let me
show you let me give you an idea real
quick
um because here is here is uh Benny
Johnson Benny Johnson says uh 25 million
views because here's the post right
here's the post
um it's 25 million views this will save
children he says what
how will this save children
that someone [__] views the first
three seconds of this 90-minute show
right think about this okay they're
posting they're posting a 90 minute
video on Twitter
now a view is counted by how many
seconds someone actually sees the video
play right the actual video view right
and then there's what they call
Impressions okay so so Impressions this
is an impression right watch that's an
impression
that is an impression just what I did
see watch uh that's another one right oh
there's another one that's another
impression okay so it's it doesn't mean
you watched it it doesn't mean the video
played it just means you saw the post
right right here you saw the post the
daily wire post so Benny ear is a
[__] idiot 25 million views it is not
let me prove it to you because I
actually have not downloaded the new uh
version of Twitter on my phone okay
so when I go to my phone right here's
the post here's a screenshot from
earlier the daily wire this is the post
okay I even put the [__] time and my
battery and all that [__] I didn't edit
this in any way I just screenshotted my
my phone screen from earlier so no one
could accuse me of [__] making it
fake are you going out here right
there's my [__] there's my Twitter app
here's here's where he's getting
confused see it has 24 and a half
million views it's not views it's
Impressions right this is how Elon has
changed this so that these stupid [__]
can claim that they're getting more
[__] views than they really are
because if you look here see how it says
6.8 million now if you have the new
version of Twitter app on your phone
you're not gonna see this or if you're
on the desktop version you're not gonna
see this
this count
because that's part of the old app now
what is a view a view is that you have
to watch at least three seconds of this
[__] thing
so literally a 90 minute video there's
6.8 million
times that it was played at least three
seconds do you follow me do you got this
that's why that's why you wouldn't post
a video that's really long on on Twitter
I mean unless you need to right like
unless you need to it's ridiculous to
post
a really long video on Twitter
it's really stupid it's I I mean I think
it's dumb to post more than two minutes
on [__] Tick Tock or Instagram it's
dumb most people aren't gonna [__]
sit through two minutes when they're
scrolling through their social media
they're not
it's just why [__] Clips are short
it's why the three seconds is the count
time to count it as a view
if someone Scrolls all the way past it
and doesn't actually view it then it's
counted as an impression but now Elon
calls it of you so [__] chuckleheads
like Benny Johnson can say this thing
got 25 million it didn't get 25 million
views and the reason why I got so many
Impressions Benny you dumb [__]
is because
um here's
here's the um here I'll show you on
desktop so here this is the post on
desktop right
so here's the post on desktop
it's how [__] ignorant these some
[__] think we are so daily wire
there's tweet and then it shows 39
million see now it's it's got 39 million
impressions
Impressions not 39 9 million views of
the movie they're acting like 39 million
times this 90 minute [__] video has
been viewed
oh my God they can't even get 90 they
can't even get [__] 10 million
10 million three second video views this
is why you wouldn't post a full movie on
Twitter it's really stupid number one
Twitter's platform to watch videos is
[__] horrible
it's horrible it works for our show
because I can just produce it and pull
the clip up and show it to you right
it's quick but it sucks it's [__]
[__] and [__]
I mean even Facebook and Instagram
hasn't got as good as like Tick Tock is
it gotten better YouTube's really good
with shorts YouTube did a really good
job with shorts I think
and what I mean by that is like the the
viewer experience you know what I mean
like you're watching it and and it's
giving you the algorithms giving you the
right videos that you want to see
it's it's it's keeping you to keep
scrolling through the videos right I
don't think Facebook does as good as job
and Instagram doesn't do as good a job
Mark Zuckerberg just isn't good at video
as Tick Tock or or YouTube and Twitter
is garbage when it comes to this like
you you can't you can't just flip
through videos like you can YouTube
shorts or Tick Tock right to keep you on
the platform you got to go from one
place to the other to the other because
Twitter is a is an archive it's a
timeline right it's not it's not it's
it's not a delivery system it's not an
algorithmic delivery system of video
content
not only that who the [__] would sit and
watch 90 minutes
on on you on [__] Twitter this movie
why wouldn't they just post a [__]
link to go download the son of a [__]
or go stream it on a website somewhere
the reason why the reason why
is because it's garbage it's [__] no one
wants to watch it
because what you have to do the entire
time is either be a bigot or buy into
bigotry
let me tell you something 2023 this is a
tough this is a tough [__] sell man
it's a tough sell to look at Americans
and go you know what we should do we
should tell people what they can and
can't do
that's a tough sell man that I gotta and
it to these [__] Nazis it is I'm
telling you that's a tough [__] sell
and more power to them to keep going out
there and keep [__] face planting on
this stupid bigotry because people don't
buy it man they don't give a [__] and
most people who are telling you they
give a [__] out
out and about they're just saying that
because affiliation they I've seen it
all the time right you're in a circle of
people we've talked about this before
about how people vote for Republicans or
they'll say they [__] vote one way or
vote the other right
in front of people and then they do the
opposite because it's about affiliation
it's about peer pressure
and if someone gives someone in and
they're in a circle and someone's like
oh [__] Pride mom goddamn bunch of
pedophiles the people that are standing
around in a circle that'll capitulate
like a bunch of weak-minded sheep will
say like yeah yeah I don't like that
either I don't like the rainbows
everywhere
but deep down inside like who gives a
[__] man who cares who gives a [__]
who gives a [__]
no one no one gives a [__] no one gives
a [__] who someone else wants to [__]
love
or how are how what their preference is
and then this whole this whole [__]
[__] of they're sticking it in our face
they're [__] jamming in her face
these are the same [__] last
night that were all over Twitter begging
Elon Musk to put it into put it in
people's faces
stick this chick are our views in
people's face get it all up in their
timeline make the algorithm pump this
thing out 39 Million Times They begged
him begged him well in the theater of it
all right They begged him
but they're saying oh this the LGBT Q
thing is being jammed down our throats
when they're the ones that are actually
jamming [__] down people's throats I
mean that's the way they like it I think
I think that's what they're afraid of
right
ah
oh man
what a time to be alive when Ben Shapiro
the daily wire the not that Nazi Rag and
Elon Musk conspired to commit political
art commit social media theater
to act like it's being censored
yet
it's not
hmm
so I think I proved
with my uh screenshot that they don't
actually have the views they have and
really honestly that's what I'm saying
about the censorship I think they did
this so that people would go look at it
and get impressions that way they could
claim its views it was all it's all
[__] [__] it's all
[__] just like um
just like Trump's little speech
yesterday on wokism you can just kind of
see this
um Paul a friend of our show here Paul's
got some art he'd like to show because
this was Donald Trump's hair yesterday
did you notice this [__] what the
[__] is this uh so he said what they
ordered from wish
and what actually arrived
look at this look at this [__] oh man
how [__] true is this holy [__] when
you put these two together oh this is
Paul I'm gonna say it man this has got
to be one of the best ones you've ever
done it really truly is gonna be the
best I he he does a lot of good ones but
sometimes sometimes it's just about
Simplicity isn't it it's just about
Simplicity and pointing out two things
all at once
what they ordered from wish
what actually arrived
and it's so funny it's so funny because
Trump supporters like to die hard
[__] cult members they think he looks
like Wolverine right like when they see
pictures of them like oh yeah he's such
a badass and they'll do all these AI to
make him look like these muscular and
[__] and it's not even close to how
[__] fat and sluggish this the Cheeto
dust Q anoner is and and Grandpa poopy
pants always looks like [__] like total
[__] [__] even when he's got the
Trump drag on right I mean he's in Trump
drag here this is with the [__] hair
did and the [__] stupid the the
stupid suit oversized suit to make him
look bigger and then he's probably got
the [__] girdle on you know he's got
the high heels and the lifts on right so
he's in Trump drag in this [__] video
right
oh my God this is hilarious though oh
boy let's go watch the the clips of uh
Trump we'll play them later too why not
we can play him uh several different
times we're gonna we're gonna play the
um oh there's some other news too but
let's let's play the Trump Clips first
here's the first one uh he spoke earlier
in Iowa to some kind of [__]
conservative thing uh and and he he's
trying out how he doesn't like the word
woke because Rhonda Santos loves the
word book Ron DeSantis is like whoa whoa
woke woke and awoken awoken
like literally he'll say it like that
um but here he here's here's the Cheeto
dust q and honor Grandpa poopy pants
with this uh wish.com Wolverine haircut
a hairdo that he had on yesterday let's
listen to him in Iowa what he thinks
about Ron desantis's war on wokism it's
gotten sick and I don't like the term
well because I hear woke woke woke you
know it's like just a term that use half
the people can't even Define it they
don't know what it is
it's gone sick oh man in that shitty we
gotta agree with this guy oh man hmm
surely he couldn't be hypocritical about
this there's no way right oh that's
right he was on a Town Hall last night
with Sean Hannity which I'm going to
show you a picture of the audience too
oh my God I mean or a whack of the
audience I should say there's not much
enthusiasm behind this fat slob but here
here's Donald Trump and a town hall with
Sean Hannity see if you can pick up on
the word that he the term that he's
people shouldn't be using because they
don't even know what it is even he even
spot it a lot of things going on with
our military with the woke and all this
nonsense and not they're not learning to
fight and protect us from some very bad
people
they want to go woke they want to go
woke that's all they talk about now I
see letters that are being sent it's
horrible
what so woke bad woke good right he
loves the term whoa get the [__] out of
here he's just pissed off that Rhonda
Santos has captured this word right
which he really shouldn't be look look
Donnie Ronnie has got problems with the
wokism right he's got problems with he's
got the woke mind virus he talks about
it a lot he projects it a lot and Ron
DeSantis can't think about anything else
but his but his woke mind virus because
he does he's got this virus of the brain
it's bigotry it's Fascism and he just
can't help himself but be a goddamn
[__] Nazi and it's it's his woke mind
virus that he's got Don don't fall for
it I mean you can use the word woke and
really honestly this is a stupid battle
to have ah man I want you guys to fight
over much I want you guys to fight over
way more substantive stuff like um the
Disney fight that's all man let's talk
about substance there for the Republican
primary how about how about how about
March April and May of 2020 during the
pandemic
of who loved fauci more ah you couldn't
get more substantive than that you you
[__] sludge buckets
go fight over that that's the [__] I
want to see don't fight over the word
woke man that's our fight Donny that's
our fight to fight over the word woke
don't you know that antifa's all over
that
oh here's uh let me see if I can find
this picture uh because oh man the
Hannity the Hannity uh Town Hall was
horrible
um apparently because no one showed up
well there was a few people there but
they had a lot more [__] chairs out
than than what they had people
um let's see if I can get the back shot
because they always had the front shot
with the cameras right she always get
the yo you always see
um the camera shot where it looks like
they have a huge audience
but that's just not the case at this
Hannity Town Hall
here's an actual photo of it from from
the back of the room okay
here it is
see how many of these chairs are
completely empty bleachers completely
empty look at this [__]
these [__] can't draw flies
Okay listen to me when I tell you this
and I've been saying it over and over
and over again
this idea that Republicans in these
fascists and Donald Trump and Ron
DeSantis have huge followings is all
[__] just like last night when
[__] daily wire conspire with Elon
Musk to make it seem like they were
being censored
is all a bunch of [__] it's [__]
fake it's not real
this just like I just showed you they're
bragging about how it's got 30 40
million views and it doesn't even really
have 10 million views
I would love to see daily wire release
their analytics on this [__] video
from their dashboard
there's a professional dashboard inside
Twitter that would show what's the
average watch time of that [__] video
and how many people actually viewed it
for that amount of time they won't do it
they won't do it because it's all
[__] that's why they act like it was
censored that's why they act like this
town hall was a big deal that's why they
moved the [__] cameras up for Fox
News so you can't see all these empty
[__] seats
come on man it's all fraud the big lie
that was told to us isn't that Donald
Trump won the election in 2020 the big
lie is that there's enough [__]
people that like this [__] and
he's got an actual following
that's that's the [__] lie and yeah
does he have cult members and yeah is it
a large number of people yeah people are
[__] dumb people are stupid in this
country what are you gonna do don't hate
on me because Americans are [__]
uneducated and Americans are dumber than
dog [__] don't blame me
don't blame me for pointing out the
[__] fact it is it's true if 10 or 12
believe that Donald Trump should be
president of the United States there's
10 or 12 percent of people in this
country that aren't smart enough to work
themselves out of a [__] wet paper
sack okay got it good
now once you start there and realize
that it's such a small [__]
percentage of people who believe this
nonsense in the [__] first place and
understand that the biggest lie the
biggest fraud that has ever been [__]
told us is that these [__]
somehow are representing the majority of
Americans this [__] [__] where they
say oh this country is split in half it
is not split in half
if you believe polls at all any of them
you would go look at them and see that
on every single [__] issue liberalism
wins every [__] time every
single [__] time Way Beyond 50
[__] percent Way Beyond it
most people in this country if they went
by their ideology instead of their
stupid [__] affiliation we wouldn't
have a republican controlling anything
in this [__] country because not only
are they a bunch of [__] crazy ass
radical fascist but they're dumber than
dog [__] and don't know how to govern
they don't
at all not a single [__] bit do they
know how to govern
that's why Hakeem Jeffries and the
Democrats passed the debt ceiling deal
it was it was speaker Jeffries that
passed that deal with his caucus
and save the American economy
because [__] Kevin McCarthy Donald
Trump Marjorie Taylor green don't know
how to govern hey metal rules V I'm I
want to welcome you to the show this is
Kami trash and I'm glad you're here to
watch the whole thing I hope you
subscribe and I hope you come back every
[__] day to watch this maybe
eventually your [__] brain will won't
will unmelt
and here's some real [__] facts not
some [__] that you've been [__]
fed to on elon's Twitter thanks for
thanks for coming
and come back every day or you're
welcome we love we love people who love
us but boy I love people who hate me oh
man I love the people who love to hate
me oh man those kind of trolls are the
ones I want
and this is Kami trash Oh Kami trash if
you think I'm a communist man then you
haven't [__] listened to me for more
than 20 [__] minutes you God damn
Maga sheep that's right someone says
manga sheep
oh [__]
[Music]
oh um big Stephan wants to know who the
name was uh of that troll yeah sure I'll
give you the name of the troll
why not there you go metal rules V call
me tread he's calling the show Tommy
trash or me call me trash or maybe I
don't know I guess I'm a communist well
see that's the thing is you point out
that fascism's bad and and Republicans
are a bunch of Nazis
and they're like oh you're a communist
as if it's going to offend me to call me
a communist because I'm I'm not a
communist
so it doesn't offend me to call me that
I don't get all [__] butt hurt
because someone calls me a communist but
when I call when I call Republicans and
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis
Marjorie Taylor green a bunch of [__]
Nazis they get [__] triggered like
you wouldn't believe oh my God they get
[__] triggered like crazy
it's insanity
but keep coming back man keep coming
back keep putting in the comments it
helps out the algorithm too again don't
forget to subscribe
metal and that way you can get your
daily dose of Kami trash every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's fun when Nazis come and call you a
comedy because you call them because you
point out that they're a bunch of
fascists they're like oh you're you're
just one of them dirty Captain
quit calling me a Nazi you
communist dude
good luck to you
okay yeah but you should
come listen every day
you should come listen every day maybe
just maybe eventually after hearing it
enough you understand that you're the
[__] sheep and you're the dumb
[__] who doesn't know what
you're talking about
oh Hannah see this is you guys are the
best audience in the world this is why
Hannah says full metal fascist
ah full metal fascist yeah that's great
thank you Hannah
for watching the Tony Michaels podcast
do you know that we are censored on the
up wire
I'm not really sure I don't think it was
my show I mean I got the first like the
the first uh warning and then another
show on the up wire is get the strike so
we're not able to stream the up wire
right now so if you know the people on
up wire
um and and they get them in the chat
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
YouTube channel
welcome them with open arms tell them
how much you love to have them over here
too so
it's great that's great that's great
that's great um let's do this let's take
a break real quick I'm gonna check on
Gabe Sanchez see where he's at I'm gonna
start to get the um bonehead of the week
loaded because that's what we got to do
we got to get the bone out of the week
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
[Music]
Tony Michaels podcast
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome
we're gonna do bonehead of the week here
really soon you got it coming up I think
it's one of your games's favorite
favorite segment every single Friday
here's what happens
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
you'll follow us on Twitter you can vote
every single week for bone of the week
you vote you decide who is on the
bonehead of the week who is the bonehead
of the week
and we break it down for you here on the
Tony Michaels podcast let me give you a
little history on both end of the week
did you know that bonetta week was a
separate show at one time and it was on
the weekend that's right so we used to
do the Tony Michaels podcast once a week
it was once a week
once a week right
and it was for two hours
and then we decided we do every single
day but we did bone of the week on the
weekends so we had the Wednesday show
and then we did like a Saturday show for
bonehead of the week
but what we decided to do was do every
single weekday for two full hours we
would do it I mean as long as you know
when I say we I mean me and then
sometimes when Gabe Sanchez decides the
show
this [__] man listen the audience knows
on Monday you're going to be in full
control so you can do anything you want
on Monday oh man what I also could do is
I could just be like I could walk in on
Monday and be like hey everyone today's
Monday and you know what
how about you treat yourself enjoy the
next two hours without me or Tony having
to talk oh is that what you I mean hey
you run the show on Monday so I mean who
knows I could run it early I could cut
it short oh man you're really gonna piss
the audience off I mean hey you do you
man
think of me think of me like a cheat day
right like she yeah every day so you're
like the ice cream in the cake of of
your yeah yeah like normally during the
week you're like this is my normal like
uh meat and potatoes right and then
you're like one day you just mix it up
confuse the metabolism you know throw
throw wrench in the mix yeah I see you
know that's a that's a pretty good
weight loss strategy it might be a good
audience loss strategy too and I don't
know I don't know I mean the bounce back
could be good it could be that that
could be true but like I said I come
back Wednesday it could be the biggest
show we've ever done ever who knows man
I'm gonna be setting records uh what I
will say is I reached out to a couple
people but one person so Dara is gonna
be in Bedminster uh
so I was like oh you know maybe you
should pick up some classified documents
so we'll we'll see if she does that okay
um and then I uh I reached out to
someone else but they were like oh no
I'm gonna be at the White House I was
like oh okay oh okay [__] oh my god well
son of a [__] we can't have anyone who
goes to the White House on this show you
know that you know I told him I told him
I was like you should live stream and
they're like oh I'll see what I can get
away I can get away with yeah well you
know you know it's funny because um
we I I'm never gonna get invited to the
White House and really honestly even if
I was invited to the White House I
probably wouldn't accept like you really
don't want me there that's not yeah I
can only imagine what a tight-lipped uh
Tony would be at the White House yeah
well I mean what would be funny is I
show up in my [__] hat in my black
t-shirt you know what I mean in my
[__] hate I mean it's in a you know
like who's the [__] bum that showed
up at the goddamn Winehouse right
because I wouldn't go in like a suit and
all kinds of dressed up and [__] I'd go
as me it would but I feel like you'd
have to you'd have to bring like a blue
[__] hat you want right you might
have to you might have to make a a
custom design no I know but you might
have to also like make a slightly
censored version
hey hey White House if you're out there
I would come if you will let me give Joe
Biden a blue [__] man that would be
my that would be my conditions to go to
the White House um is that is that dark
Brandon gets a blue [__] em hat I mean
maybe maybe a blue [__] hat in a dark
Brandon shirt that could be that
strength we could do that I don't or
give him a red hat and make him say make
Red Hats wearable again oh
I'm just saying
is that red hat one word or is that two
n-r-h-w-a make Red Hats wearable again
yeah yeah I mean I I like the the red is
my favorite [__] em hat oh yeah yeah
just because it's mocking the Red Hats
yes well I like red I like the color red
okay I mean it's not my favorite
conservative well I mean I'm not it's
not my favorite color right black is
black gray you know I'm simple kind of
[__] you know yeah I mean who isn't
right right well in my fashion sense and
that's the thing is I really don't have
fashion since probably so I mean look
when I'm from the ocean
no judgment no judgment you're a product
of your environment
that's what I'm trying to say look I'm
trying to have self-deprecating human
here I don't need you to pile on my
friend well I'm sorry I thought we were
just getting ready for Monday you know
Ah that's true that's true well let's
get ready for bone end of the week
because we got bone end of the week
um right here you know what we'll just
do the we'll see if we look oh here it
is Boom
head Magic
now we is I was telling the audience
that bonehead used to be like a a
separate day a separate segment it was
on the weekend yeah yeah it used to be a
Saturday show well it was Saturday
release
you had this idea because because we
used to do one show a week and we were
trying to figure out if we were going to
do it every single day and you're like
you know what let's try doing one on the
weekend we'll do one on Wednesday we're
doing weekend like what are we gonna do
and I I always said the word bonehead
and you were like well why don't we do
like a poll where we have bonehead of
the week I'm like oh that's perfect or
no you you said let's do a poll and I'm
like let's do a bowl like bone of the
week because you had this idea of
centering at the show The Weekend show
around the word bonehead yeah use the
word bone in a lot yeah and so I was
like let's just let people vote and then
we'll [__] mock them what right
whatever yeah right people will just
mock them and then we uh it naturally
ends we did bone of the week we came up
with Alpha cook we came up with the
dishonorable mention and the reason why
is because like by the time we put
someone on the pole and then the poll
would end and then the news cycle would
go through another one or two cycles we
realized oh [__] those people are real
yeah this is enough stuff and you know
and there were times like this is the
main story so like this person's
definitely gonna be in it for the week
right but by the time we get to Thursday
when let's say the poll ended you'd be
like well two of them are like I guess
still relevant right not so no one even
remembers the story almost and we had
that where we were like wait why did we
put dead person on the right right well
every once in a while like even today
here's here's the um
here's the boneheads today yeah and I'm
struggling to know exactly why why I
mean obviously man Walsh but yeah
Marjorie Taylor green I know we're gonna
get to that and Donald Trump I mean
there's a hundred reasons why he could
be on that this oh yeah yeah I mean
Margaret Taylor Green's a big one I have
a theory
that uh why is she well it's related to
why she's on bonehead of the week I see
I see I see but you know this bonehead
thing went over so well that when we
when we did every single weekday we're
like well we can't lose bonehead right
so that's why we put it because it was
always on the weekend and it's always a
good way to end the week I feel like
because it's a fun segment it's
something a little different on Friday
so like let's just [__] do it on
Friday in the last part of the show
we'll just do the bonehead there it'll
be a segment so that is why that's the
story of how bonehead became this
segment so let's start it right now
bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week this Edition coming straight
at ya
straight is the thing that Matt Walsh is
scared of he's terrified oh boy it's not
straight so Matt Walsh is on the
bonehead of the week Marjorie Taylor
green she's undefeated
is she though is she and then Donald J
Trump the Cheeto dust q and honor
Grandpa poopy pants himself made it on
to the list
boy this is quite the ugly list that we
got yeah the three
I don't want to say Three Amigos yeah
the three yeah something Monsters the
three Gremlins the three ogres the three
trolls the three
I don't know what man well let's start
with let's start with Marjorie Taylor
green all right because the reason why
is because with Matt Walsh there's
another one person in the DM that I
think that will kind of will let them
mesh together there so let's start with
Marjorie Taylor green why is the petty
Yeti
why is the petty Eddie the pipe bar
excuse me pipe bomber what why do I want
to call it a pipe bomber
is that that's that's a good reason
that's a good question I should I should
say hmm is she getting nervous about
this pipe mom narrative well it seems
like she is uh here's a clip this is the
reason uh that I decided to put her on
the list
this is the official reason
yeah this is the official reason because
you're the one who wanted Marjorie
Taylor green on I think yeah yeah I mean
look there's a lot of reasons why we
could put her on every week uh but this
one I feel like uh she's really okay so
like obviously the first one is the
whole debt ceiling deal right right
that's that's where it started and then
on like two days ago she did her uh
Marjorie MTG Battleground or Battlefield
whatever the [__] it's called it's on
the it's on the trader TV Steve bannon's
Network okay okay so
she had an episode of this show it was
the same show where she was on with
Brian Glenn and she was like oh strip
clubs we should get rid of strip clubs
you know now we love strip clubs so this
clip we're gonna watch is from this is
from this show this show yeah okay isn't
it weird that members of Congress have
shows instead of like being members of
Congress you know there's a there's a
there's a Ted Cruz what was that that
I'm working on in the background that
deals with this whole well specifically
talking to him because he was recently
on Newsmax and he was like please you
gotta donate donate don't like some
[__] Lindsey Graham Marco Rubio type
[__] but he was begging for money
traveling and the theme of that one is
like
this guy's bagging for money like what
has he done right he hasn't done
anything he he flies away he abandons
his constituents he doesn't do anything
and they're all the same they've got a
podcast a show they try to like build
money from other people
even though they're paid six billion six
figure salaries they have incredible
benefits incredible Health Care they
they are set up for life you know
they're using insider trading yeah yeah
insider trading doesn't affect them at
all right and that yeah and that's
something else where it's like that
should be you know cut off across the
board Democrat and Republican there's a
lot of opinions about that and my
opinion is is that it's hard to actually
it's hard to do that it's hard it's
difficult because they know [__] that
we're not going to know before we know
it right you're just not going to be
able to not brief Congress on some of
these things and then to actually
prevent them from [__] investing is
kind of ridiculous it's kind of like
saying a President's child can't ever do
business overseas because they're the
President's child like what are you
talking about then so you're going to
affect all kinds of people and your
family and [__] because this person is
[__] ridiculous that's that's bad hey
I'm just that's Republican logic right
there well right right this is
meganomics
magnanomics but this clip speaking of
meganomics this is the clip that um LED
you to put her officially on the bone of
the week because that's the other thing
about bone of the week that people will
know is Gabe Sanchez this is kind of his
brainchild and I kind of give him the
last word on like the polls and stuff
I'll put my suggestions in there but
generally speaking that's why I'm always
like what why is this person because I
I'm truly asking him in the moment why
that he put these people on the bonehead
because sometimes I know it's very clear
but here's the here's the clip that has
led the petty Eddie pipe bomber on to
the bonehead of the weak pull four as a
matter of fact they walk back and forth
in front of the same video camera
multiple times strolling up and down the
street wait wait is this her evaluating
the footage of the pipe bomber is that
what this is yeah
are you [__] me no no this is what
this is one part of the episode where
she's she goes in and talks yeah well
yes she is uh I have a theory behind why
she's doing this
um because she's gone back into if you
notice the language in the in the type
of uh
argument she's using on Twitter these
days she's leaning back into this Q Anon
the FBI is uh is is Joe Biden's regime
and the doj is corrupt all stuff and I
honestly think and I was checking with
the last night I honestly think the
reason that she shifted her narrative is
because she went from voting Kevin
McCarthy in the speaker of the house
then she did these programs she's like
oh I was a victim of the internet I
believe Q Anon and I shouldn't have
believed it and right conspiracies right
and she tried to because she wanted back
on she wanted to be back on Fox News
Right Fox News wouldn't let that crazy
ass on yeah so she was trying to Rebrand
so she could get back on Fox News to
spread her [__] and so now with this
uh as as things are beginning to fall
apart for Kevin McCarthy right where
he's like I'm super excited I love this
deal this deal is great yeah
these Republicans are like uh Kevin
McCarthy's a rhino and now they're
calling uh Marjorie Taylor Greener Rhino
because
she is supportive of Kevin McCarthy's
position on this bill and so now all
these like deep Maga rooted people are
like no no she's a rhino she's a rhino
she's a rhino and I honestly believe
that what she's doing here is there's
two parts to it the first is she's
trying to say no no I'm not a rhino I'm
I'm deep in it I'm gonna get the deepest
I'm queuing on full-throated and we are
going to push the conspiracy that the
doj like even if you look at the
comments or the replies that she's had
this week she's like oh so you're
admitting that you're part of the doj
and the FBI planning January 6 and
you're like what we're back to this okay
well because here's here's what she did
she's she is calling to release all the
January 6 footage to the public is what
she's calling for she wants it all and
all these sedition hunters and capital
capital Ryder hunters and all these
internet sleuths are like [__] yeah do
that [__] release all the footage and
we will [__] find these people you
[__] bonehead do that [__] do it
and we'll find out who the pipe bomber
is is basically what these internet
salutes are saying like yeah do that be
transparent about it and we'll [__]
be transparent about it and and all of a
sudden they realized oh that's probably
not a good idea to do that right and the
reason why is because the internet will
have their way with us and have their
way with Trump supporters and they'll
basically out everyone that's in this
footage because now it's public
information you put it out in the public
it's public information what what like
here's the here's the tweet that you
sent me last night which is which goes
to this narrative that she's trying to
push right now which is the idea that
um you know she says
uh so you were this one person Hunter S
Thompson machine gun says yes release
all the footage so my team and I can run
the raw footage through our AI filters
and identify every last Mega
insurrectionist and then Marjorie Taylor
green says so were you one of the CIA
there on Jan on j6 helping organize the
little plan like we me
okay we we have established right now
there are truths that exist in this
world and those truths are that people
like the proud boys and The Oath Keepers
and others because we've seen part of
the footage we've seen we've seen part
of the footage we've also seen the the
recent court cases that have indicted
and charged these people with sedition
conspiracy and as a period their peers
found them guilty with that exactly
so when when she says oh you were part
of the CIA planning this [__]
because now what she's trying to do is
she's trying to maneuver herself to say
oh no no no guys listen I'm not Rhino
I'm going after these people I'm trying
to release the truth so we can expose
the doj and the FBI for the the traders
that they are and then on top of that I
think what she's doing with this video
is she's trying to position this to be
like look look I'm I'm talking about the
pipe bomber footage here I'm trying and
if it's not me right right and I'm
trying to reveal the truth about what
happened and in the event that somebody
comes forward with evidence to prove
that I was the pipe bomber just know
that I'm not the pipe bomber but they're
trying to silence me by some sort of
conspiracy to make me seem like I'm the
pipe bomber even it's almost like a pipe
bomber it's like someone ran in the room
and said who's the pipe bomb marginal
Green's like
it's not me all right let's let's listen
to more of how she's not the not the
bite bomber that hey Don Junior that's
how you actually yeah he's the
quotations even stopping to put a face
mask on when another person is
approaching them coming down the
sidewalk this is not the behavior of
someone that is prepared to commit a
crime you know plant bombs that would
explode and kill people actually this is
the behavior of someone that seems to be
wanted to be seen on video camera and
isn't concerned about getting caught
oh so she's saying she's being framed is
what she's saying here she I see what
she's trying to get ready when if and
when it comes out of who this person was
pipe bomber uh wise she's going to say
oh look guys look I was the one who
tried to reveal the real truth
the the exposed these people for who
they are this corrupt government this
Joe Biden's regime I guarantee she's
gonna be like the only person who was
talking about it was me and why would I
talk about the thing that I did
hmm just saying I'm just saying let's
continue her little twisted logic here
let's also talk about what the FBI knows
about this person the FBI early on in
2021 released reward money up to five
hundred thousand dollars to be for
someone to turn in this so I gotta admit
it's so funny to watch her talk about
who the pipe bomber is and then quote
the FBI who she wants to defund yeah
like literally she was posting her
defund the FBI t-shirts the other day on
her Twitter account and here this [__]
is quoting the FBI and she's gonna tell
us what the FBI knows and why that's
proof that she's being framed what the
[__] I can already see this coming and I
haven't watched this video let's
continue called pipe bomber they even
have uh descriptions of their clothing
they have pictures of this person's
shoes they had all of this information
on the FBI website and they were
supposedly hunting this person down well
here's what I want you to know that's
happened since then since this time in
January of 2021 pipe bomber got a
divorce literacy theories
and he's got a new boo yeah and she's
got a new January 6th yeah it's January
5th 2021. the pipe bomber has gotten a
divorce right gotten really big into
CrossFit even really were before no [__]
do they post video does the pipe bomber
post videos online of them doing
CrossFit I mean with like Confederate
flags many people uh you know sources
have indicated to Marjorie Taylor green
that they do post videos of CrossFit you
know with those shoes and that hoodie a
very fit pipe bomber yeah very very okay
stocky right bomber who also has a
tendency to yell at other
Representatives on the capitol steps and
uh try to you know then act like the
victim there's a pattern here guys
there's a pattern here and it's all
about talk about the things
you can film it doesn't matter she'll
play the she'll play the victim and then
she'll she'll be like whoa whoa whoa
guys guys look I I clearly couldn't have
been me yeah sure I said my name on
camera but it wasn't me do you do you
think that this is the new boyfriend's
uh suggestion to do this
I mean he is a
reporter so I wouldn't be surprised if
he was just like just like she's not the
pipe bomber
he's a reporter like she's not the bite
bomber like I wouldn't I wouldn't be
surprised if he was like uh
look you gotta spin this narrative right
look well he was like he's like look
what do you have because they're Pro
she's probably assessing like oh man I
got all these people calling me uh Rhino
and I'm I'm not I'm not their their
their uh they're representative anymore
and I'm gonna get voted out in the next
you know whatever but maybe you'll think
I'm the pipe bomber that tried to bomb
the DNC right right so there's like all
these weird they're all these weird
things where she's like I can go against
it to expose the thing that the doj and
the FBI aren't looking into or I can go
into and be like yes I was the pipe
bomber and I am the cause of this whole
situation don't you like either way
she's like trying to make it but I think
honestly what she's trying to do is
she's trying to position herself as the
victim per usual
and say look why would I
supposedly the pipe bomber talk about
the pipe bomber and really dig into
what's been going on if I were if I were
like that that seems like not a smart
thing to do right like yeah I mean it is
we are on bonehead of the week and it is
Marjorie Taylor girl who is undefeated
until today because I I'll break it to
you she's not the winner this week which
and stops her undefeated spree here uh
but let's listen to more about the
bombing spree that she is gonna claim
she was framed for launched all over the
internet if especially on Twitter and
there's been many theories over who the
bot the pipe bomber no just one that's
one thing yeah I just can't seem to find
it's really interesting though that the
FBI is able to find the grandmas you
know and and the different Trump
supporters that walk through the capitol
aimlessly
videotaping the capital or holding an
American flag oh one of the ones that
never caused any damage never fought
with police officers just walked through
the capitol should have been able to
find those people go to their homes in
the middle of the night
um arrest them uh the Department of
Justice was able to charge them because
they were on camera they committed
felonies it's called breaking and
entering it's a felony on its own right
even if you just go in and you just film
yeah it's still like as soon as she's
like oh how could they do this they come
after these people it's like yeah you do
realize that you guys are so so upset
and so paranoid about the covet vaccine
giving you 5G microchips that you that
could track you and the whole time you
had your [__] phone in your pocket
which is literally a GPS tracking device
you don't think that when you walk into
the capitol which is proven here that
your phone automatically becomes a a
track device within the building okay
and also Beyond right so the idea is
she's like oh no these people came in uh
they were just waving their American
flag and this and then it's like yeah
they're Grandma's is she talking about
Lauren bobert when she says that no no
she's talking about that one photo no
you know Lauren bober is going to be a
grandma I know I know
yeah I know I know I mean but and
they're figured maybe that's what she's
talking about the the video or the photo
that she's talking about is the grandma
with the glasses who's like waving
American flag look Granite granny granny
shouldn't have been an Insurrection
isn't granny when I got arrested but
here's the thing that photo isn't from
there I think it's from the Georgia
capital oh [__] so it's not even real of
course it isn't so here's the thing is
that um there was reports this week or
was it last week that the FBI has
identified the vehicle that the pipe
bomber actually used Ryan Glenn's car
[Laughter]
that would be [__] hilarious if it's
the [__] reporters man got out of the
back seat
white the bike just spit on the ground
white or it's uh put on the mask and
then proceeded to go drop the ball or
instead of or instead of rsbn with Brian
Glenn it's uh it's just the CrossFit gym
that marjor taylored at one point yeah
with the vehicle wrap you know what's
funny about this is she's saying she's
being framed and if you if you like
rewind and remember who Marjorie Taylor
green is and how she became a member of
Congress and the foresight that people
would have had to have to frame her to
be the pipe bomber is [__] ridiculous
she was sworn in like like just six days
before
a few days before why was why was she
meeting in December to talk about a
meeting like right it's it's weird but
but you would have to have the foresight
that oh this person is going to be
relevant right and you and you wouldn't
dream in December 2020 that Marjorie
Taylor green would be relevant in the
Republican party now you would also not
dream that they would be doing a lot of
stuff that they're doing right now but I
mean it's it's par for the course for
these [__] boneheads and that's why I
keep telling you don't don't
underestimate their stupidity Donald
Trump is going to be their nominee stop
acting like they're [__] normal stop
doing that stop acting like they're not
normal they are the party of Marjorie
Taylor green that is their party that's
who they are that's their [__]
personality now act like it [__] per
you don't have to pretend like there's
something that they're not they are this
but you would never dream in 2020 that
someone would have the foresight to
[__] frame her for the pipe bombing
right yeah but you're gonna follow her
logic like No One's Gonna frame you you
dummy you weren't no one gave a [__]
about you right in [__] G on January
6th and beyond that it's like why do you
need a pardon right what are you trying
to Pardon yourself from that's a felony
what would it be the fact that you
placed I don't know an explosive device
near multiple buildings that could
potentially have casualties with
American Lives why would you need to do
that uh why would you need it why would
you need a pardon why would you even
inquire about something so early on in
your tenure as a representative of the
United States it seems a bit suspicious
right well there's a lot of suspicious
stuff on the internet
um in the last few days and last night
we launched as I think what I think is
that the daily wire Matt Walsh and Ben
Shapiro conspired with Elon Musk to fake
censor this video so that they could
pump The Impressions so that this
morning they could brag about how many
views it was do you think they also did
do you think
so in terms of the two people who
resigned because I believe that they
were fired or they came to an agreement
with Elon Musk which is Elle Irwin who
is the person that became the new head
of trust and safety at Twitter yesterday
resigned from Twitter and she was the
person that was working with Matt taibi
and also
um
I believe I believe I believe the reason
why they probably resigned are fired
whatever happened I believe what we're
going to find out is that Elon Musk
[__] did all this stupid [__] and the
con he he was he was texting with Ben
Shapiro and Matt Walsh and they made all
this [__] up they made the whole thing
up it's all [__] made up and it's all
for this Impressions because that's why
Matt Walsh is on bonehead of the week
because last night he was asking for the
manager or the owner of Twitter which is
our design I don't mention Elon Musk
because this is all one in the same
story right
the other and the other reason was
because uh Elon Musk the reason that
he's on as dishonorable mentioned is
because as of late and I'm sure the
value will go down he's already lost uh
two-thirds of the value of Twitter which
means that he bought it for 44 billion
again he overpaid great investment but
yeah very very I mean for anyone out
there wondering if Elon is a genius and
then like a especially an investment
genius and if you think he's great with
money you're a dumb [__] like
you should do the opposite of what Elon
does if you want to do smart things with
your money
um but let's go back to the story about
the the daily wires
um because this movie is so bad the
movie is what is a woman and it's Matt
Walsh just going around the entire world
filming himself asking people 30 minutes
last night what is a woman how horrible
is it is it really bad it was not good
because it's Matt Walsh trying to
trying to appear smart right he's like I
thought that's what he I thought that's
what he's always doing yeah but you say
just in this film I thought that was his
whole stick well he had a whole movie
where it like starts off with these kids
celebrating the birthdays and it's of
course it starts with children
you know girls and he's sitting there
and he's like what is a woman is it
based on the things we're giving blah
blah blah and the boys
why why does the question what does a
woman have to do with [__] children
do you see how their [__] minds are
so goddamn corrupt with this [__] the
way that he tries to position Jesus and
again I only watched like 30 minutes so
I scrub through some areas so basically
at one point he goes to this African
village and he tries to get an
understanding of what they think a woman
is and understanding what the gender
roles are in their their culture their
society uh which is
I think is a apples to oranges
comparison because you're taking
someone's experience that is different
but also culturally right it's wait wait
wait you're telling me wait you're
telling me that Matt Walsh doesn't
understand anything but white culture
white culture yeah yeah well and what I
mean by white culture is white culture
that's been appropriated by all the
others right right but of course I gotta
go to yeah he's like I gotta go to
Africa and I gotta get a point of view
that I know it's going to be most likely
a conservative not conservative
political but conservative
and then of course he goes well it's not
white people that are saying this it's
also African people that are saying oh I
see where he's going so then yeah
another another so there's a whole
another section where he goes to San
Francisco and he tries to like catch
people off the street in the Castro and
be like what is a woman and then he goes
like well what if I were to say I were
this well what if I were to say or a dog
and then there's another point where he
goes to a college campus and talks to a
uh so does any of this have like a three
line like art make sense at all no it's
other than just he doesn't know what a
woman is the through line yes the
through line that he has is that Matt
Walsh is most likely in some capacity an
abusive man
this is this is what he's trying to
project is what you're saying yeah I'm
just saying based on what I see and
basically toxic masculinity from front
to back I'm not saying I'm not saying
it's physical but I am most likely going
to infer based on what I saw that it's
verbal and it's emotional right and how
he interacts with other people to be
like well I'm going to let's talk about
circular logic let's talk about this
wouldn't you infer that this like he's
trying to use big words
to make someone feel less than them
right and I wouldn't be surprised if he
has that same type of ideology in his
home for his wife and also his children
right by the way I feel so sorry for on
all fronts uh that they have to deal
with that as a father uh and in the
throughout the whole movie that I saw
like I haven't watched the whole thing
but like I scrubbed through you know the
the the the first part the middle and
the end and basically the through line
there is that he's trying to say that
people don't have an answer for what a
woman is and they're just trying to make
it up and use it as an excuse in society
yeah it's it's again I I I'll again I've
said this to Matt and I'm well he's I'll
I'll go on his stupid [__] show and
tell this to his face here's what a
woman is it's a gender that people
identify as that's what that's what a
woman is now maybe we should make a
movie that instead of what is a woman we
should make it did Matt Walsh ever get a
hug like that's what that's right
I'm saying that's what the actual title
of the movie should have been right
right Matt Walsh ever get a hug against
and I will assume that no he's never
gonna well maybe if he did it was under
like maybe forced uh conditions he's
like hug me or else right right uh but
again he likes you know this is the same
guy that did the weird front seat car
videos with his cell phone on his
YouTube channel where he would talk
about teenagers having sex like
literally that teenage sex and teenagers
having sex and having sex with teenagers
he would do these weird weird videos
that's that's how that's I mean what's
here think about it the people at Daily
wire saw those videos like yeah let's
have this guy on like they saw the weird
front seat videos
I think what you have to realize is that
the type of man
man that Matt Walsh's is very much like
the Jordan Peterson right they align
themselves and I can identify with a
group of people who feel so
I don't know villainized right and they
feel like they're the victim and they
have to say whoa okay guys look look
life is tough as a straight white male
and it shouldn't be because at one point
we are on top we were on top in terms of
race gender uh socioeconomic job status
all this stuff right and they're like
now our position as a white straight
male is threatened by all of these
groups who now want to have a say in
life [__] that and so that is the thing
in the half and so all these people who
think that they should be given this
this privilege right they they didn't
have to work for it or rather they did
work for it and they earned it just by
being alive and that's the logic that
Jordan Peterson daily um
everyone at the daily wire Whitney
Johnson here yeah yeah little little
Benji Johnson he's the same one well
look at this and this is the thing that
I think or the reason why this is all
fake because Benny Johnson here is quote
tweeting the daily wires post of this
[__] movie now here's the first thing
number one why would you post a 90
minute video on Twitter that's the
dumbest [__] thing ever it's the
worst platform to watch a 90 minute
video on the worst the worst what it
tells me is that daily wire couldn't
sell this [__] thing so they gotta
give it away for free and they gotta
convince people that a shitload of
people watched it and what they did was
is they contacted Elon and say hey we
want you to intentionally censor us so
we can act like we're bitching about it
and then it'll create this buzz on
Twitter that we're bitching to you about
us being censored that's what happened
I'm convinced of it and this tweet
proves it because Benny Johnson says 20
million 25 million views they this will
save children [__] out of here you piece
of garbage yeah I'm not exactly sure how
this is supposed to save children and on
top of that the thing that I would say
is
no one has the attention span okay like
as someone who has ADHD I can tell you
right now that my time limit cap unless
I'm like oh I gotta scrub through this
video to find the clip that I'm looking
for and most likely I'll just download
the video and just do it myself
but if I'm on Twitter and I have to
watch a video like [__] I have been
trained you know through Twitter and
other apps that's like all right two
minutes that's my attention span right
and that's that's why Twitter is 220.
it's not because they arbitrarily pick
220. they did a lot of [__] research
to figure out what the appropriate time
on their [__] platform was and that
time was two minutes and 20 seconds
right and it probably also had to do
with the fact they're like look if we
can compress this video down to two
minutes and 20 seconds we'll save
ourselves like this is the max amount of
data storage it would require there's
probably multiple things like they
tested they're like all right look
attention span 220. there's a lot of
data they collected is what you're
saying the other thing too the other
thing too is Elon has changed how views
what is a view and what's it called he's
calling Impressions views now right it
used to be that a view would show and
and I've got the old version of Twitter
on my phone so I got a screenshot of the
old version I'm gonna show you here why
it's this is [__] proof of this is
all [__] made up last night all this
[__] was made up this whole Karen I want
the manager [__] was all made up to pump
the Impressions so here is here is a
screenshot from my [__] cell phone at
9 47 central time this morning I didn't
edit this you can even see the scroll
bar over here right and I sent this to
you too I think so this is the [__]
post from the daily wire if you look
down here at this point it shows 24.5
million views this is the stupid
impression number that if Elon is
calling to use now it's not views that's
a [__] lie it's Elon lying to you
here Twitter is lying to you
intentionally to me what I'm seeing here
right now is that so look here a quarter
right but look here here because I have
the old version of the app I still see
the video views now a video view is
still to my knowledge it's still you
have to watch three seconds of this
video to be counted as this 6.8 million
views think about that for a second
meaning if someone watches this for
three seconds and moves on it's now
counted as a video view a 90 minute
movie yeah so even this number 6.8
million is not the amount of people that
watch this [__] 90 minute movie on
Twitter because Twitter is the worst
place to view video like this the worst
it's the worst platform Facebook
probably well Instagram probably being
the next and then Facebook but YouTube
and twitch and really Tick Tock is the
place where you would go watch video not
90 minutes of it but or depending on
those platforms but Twitter's the worst
so this is all [__] that's why last
night I even told you last night when it
was happening I'm like this is all
[__] they're making this [__] up
yeah Elon didn't censor them uh
Elon could make a phone call and they
would get in log in and [__] change
it in a in a matter of seconds and you
know what's really it really pisses me
off about this more than anything it's
like oh this transgender stuff this LGBT
stuff it's rammed down our throats you
jam it in our face and last night they
were mad they were mad that Elon
wouldn't jam it in people's faces right
like you [__] always project that's
why Matt Walsh is on the bone of the
week that's why Elon Musk is the
dishonorable mention this week because
they're [__] bone-ins and I didn't
fall for it I think a lot of people did
but I didn't yeah I mean that's what
it's going to be at the end of the day
you're going to find this you're gonna
you're gonna it's gonna reveal that you
know in some way shape or form that they
were in in communication but also again
we have to remember that Elon Musk is
the guy who got so pissed when his tweet
during the Super Bowl didn't perform as
well as uh Joe Biden and then had the
engineering team on a [__] Sunday
for the Super Bowl say guys I need my
tweet to show up in front of everyone's
faces because mine isn't performing as
well you're going to tell me that if
this was really the Free Speech
absolutist the guy that really cares
about making sure that everything you
can say on the Internet is unfiltered
you you're gonna tell me that he he he
wouldn't work on that immediately he
wouldn't tell everyone to be like look
I'm working on this I got the team
working on it right now we're gonna
figure it out we're gonna fix it wow he
could just go have them fix it he's done
it time and time again where something
happens he goes instead he's like oh
I'll fix it tomorrow it'll be fixed by
tomorrow exactly they wanted the whole
night to be about the stupid Karen thing
I know you have a hard out because we
got a meeting we got to go to in about
seven minutes so let's move on and then
you go ahead and go to the meeting and
then I'll finish up and then I'll I'll
join you cool um so the the alpha [__]
of the week was Kevin McCarthy this is
pretty simple on on the album and it has
to do with the actual bonehead winner
Kevin mccar earthy really stepped in it
this week when he thought he was going
to outsmart Joe Biden in this
negotiation of this deal but here's what
actually happened here's what I believe
happened is Kevin McCarthy was taking
orders from Donald Trump and when you
take orders from Donald Trump it's all
over the place it's all over the map it
doesn't make any sense it's not supposed
to make sense because he doesn't know
how [__] works and what what ended up
happening is Kevin McCarthy had to make
his deal with Hakeem Jeffries Mitch
McConnell and Chuck schimmer he had to
make those deals and Joe Biden was at
the center of that and they didn't let
that [__] get away with anything
and Mitch McConnell knew he couldn't
Mitch McConnell knew he couldn't and
Mitch McConnell didn't want to get
involved really until he had to and
Kevin McCarthy really [__] stepped on
a banana and there's a clip can you show
can you give me that clip where he's
like oh I love this deal it's the
greatest time it's the greatest ever and
you'll see why he's the bonehead but
here's the thing folks the reason why
they [__] absolutely stepped on the
rake here with this debt ceiling deal
and it appears that Hakeem Jeffries was
actually the Speaker of the House in
this negotiation and in this vote and
that's true it's true Hakeem Jeffries
brought his caucus there was more
Democrats that voted for this
[__] than there were Republicans
and Hakeem Jeffries showed it on the
floor that he's much better at being the
speaker house than Kevin McCarthy could
ever [__] dream of and and really
honestly I think the thing is that
people should take away from this this
isn't all Kevin McCarthy's fault it's
because it's Kevin McCarthy's fault
because he made deals with Donald Trump
and he put Donald Trump in power Donald
Trump is the speaker of the house and
Donald Trump doesn't know what the [__]
he's doing when it comes to government
or negotiating for that matter when they
say oh he's a master negotiator that's
all [__] it's all fraud it's all
fake he's not what he appears to be to
these moglodytes he's just not did you
find that that clip um
so um speaking of of Donald Trump Trump
and we're going to play the um uh oh
you've got it you're gonna get it in the
brand
what are you putting it in the uh on
stream yard are you giving me the
Twitter no I'm I'm giving you Twitter I
said okay because there's so many there
are so many questions
did you type in rake step Kevin McCarthy
you know I should have I probably would
have found it earlier yeah it might have
been might have been easier that way no
okay so here's here's Kevin McCarthy
explaining explaining how much he really
does truly
um like this like this bill and how
great it is and how great he thinks it
is
here it is
sometimes they hire none I'm bringing
back the next 60 billion to them so this
is great I think it's wonderful that
they voted for it because they are now
on record so they can't sit there and
yell this isn't good
well let's get the rest of the IRS agent
let's get the rest of the work
requirements let's cut more because we
are in a big debt can you see Steve
scalise in the background even Steve
scalise is like God damn this guy he is
full of [__] [__] he's doing a whole
world
ah these people so Kevin McCarthy made
it on his album
and it's great the Democrats voted for
because we're going to hold it against
them that they made sure to save the
American economy from us because we're
such [__] and we like things like
the unconstitutional debt ceiling so we
can fight and try to destroy the [__]
economy because Donald Trump wanted to
destroy the economy so he could run
against Joe Biden and say that Joe Biden
destroyed the economy when it was
actually it was an Australian County
away we lose why do we lose all the time
why do we keep losing ah [__] again
McCarthy the reason why you keep losing
is because you [__] picked out your
leader and you continue to follow your
leader which he is Gabe Sanchez he's the
bone end of the week yep he beat
Marjorie Taylor green did you see that
happening but I I think it was gonna
happen I didn't know I didn't think it
was gonna happen but it was pretty close
it was like I don't know I want to say
they're like maybe 18
percentage points off from each other
and the final final uh like uh race but
it's uh I mean I don't know you can
always rely on you can always count on
them right right they're Never Gonna Let
You Down well yeah that's me and the
bonehead of course well that's the
reason why I want to show you these
clothes these two clips because he's
he's got big legal problems this week
it's found out that yes there are tapes
of Donald Trump claiming well not only
it was he had instructed Corcoran or the
AIDS right clearly Trump had instructed
AIDS because AIDS wouldn't know to do
this but Trump had instructed AIDS and
the AIDS and instructor uh Evan Corker
and his lawyer to say don't go into that
office okay whatever you do don't go
into that office you don't have to worry
about that there's no documents there
that's what Corcoran is now saying then
you like oh wait who's this mysterious
witness turns out it's a Mar-A-Lago
maintenance dude so he was there and he
was actually part of it if I want to
remember
I hope his name is like Earl or or Wayne
actually you know what I I kind of hoped
that his name is like Jesus
well you know you know what Mar-A-Lago
you know what Mar-A-Lago they they hire
a lot of people from Jamaica Mar-A-Lago
oh yeah they hire a lot yeah yeah yeah
because it's you know Jamaica's close
and they are a lot from Jamaica but
here's the thing is that there is a
recording of Donald Trump admitting that
yes it's classified information yes it's
planned to attack Iran and yeah I
probably
um stole it so that way I could get the
live tournament Jared Kushner get two
billion dollars from the Saudis but the
thing that I love the most and I want to
mock him about which we mocked him on
the title and the thumbnail it's about
how he doesn't like the word woke so
listen to yesterday how he's trying to
tell this this crowd Rhonda santis is
dumb because he uses the word woke and
then the next clip you're going to hear
from last night only hours later and
we'll see what Donald Trump says about
woke it's gotten sick and I don't like
the term wolf because he doesn't what
it's not just a term that gives half the
people can't even Define it they don't
know what it is that's true yeah that's
true that's true I agree right I agree
with him on that oh we agree with Donald
Trump what's gonna happen here but he
says he says he doesn't like woke
everyone's talking
and when they say it they don't know
what they're talking about yeah you take
it from him let's see what he said on
the Hannity Show uh on the town hall
that no one attended I we I showed a
picture earlier to prove it but here is
here's here's Mr anti-woke on Hannity's
Town Hall let's listen to how anti-wokey
is a lot of things going on with our
military with the woke and all this
nonsense and not they're not learning to
fight and protect us from some very bad
people
that's all they talk about now I see
letters that are being sent it's
horrible does he know what woke means
because it really feels like he's just
saying and he doesn't know what it means
at CPAC he spoke this year and the theme
was
drum roll please what is it what is it
awake not woke
Donald Trump you are the bone of the
week [__] you're the bonehead of the
century my friend let's give him his
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week gave her the jump out he's
got a heart out thank you for joining us
on bone end of the week I'm just gonna
switch over to the regular thing since
we've done the actually you know we'll
do the music first and then I'll switch
over we'll make it like we always do
this has been bone of the week don't go
anywhere I got a few announcements for a
few minutes so don't go anywhere be
right back right after the bonehead
music Donald Trump bonehead of the
century
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
oh thanks for joining us here on the
Friday sorry Gabe had to jump out we got
a meeting we gotta go to and we had a
hard out so
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy
I'm glad you joined us great audience
today sorry we couldn't uh stream to
upwire if you're here from up wire
um it's sorry we couldn't stream over
there today uh YouTube is suspending us
because they don't like words we see so
show support for the up wire go to the
upwire.com that's the upwired.com or go
on YouTube and search the up wire and go
subscribe to the YouTube channel over
there it's always good to show YouTube
that hey you suspend us your Banos and
then we get more people supporting that
channel so when we come back live maybe
we'll do a special show where we only
broadcast from the up wire to show
support uh since YouTube decided to ban
us from from streaming over there today
it's [__] and speaking of [__] go
ahead and subscribe to the YouTube
channel right here the Tony Michaels
podcast you don't want to miss a single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
Pond you can also watch it live on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels all two
hours and of course you can follow us on
Twitch for free and if you're a prime
user the best thing to do
it's to link your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account you get one free
subscription with your Amazon Prime
account for twitch and you can give us
that one free subscription and we get a
couple bucks each month and it doesn't
cost you a single nickel and don't
forget if you've already subscribed to
Twitch with your Amazon Prime account
you gotta re-subscribe every month it'll
make it easy to give us a couple bucks
for free but it's worth it if it's worth
it to you it's worth it to us and we
thank you very much for showing support
on all the platforms twitch YouTube
Facebook Twitter and also downloading
every single episode on Apple Spotify
and Google the audio version is where
it's at every single afternoon you can
download it on your favorite directories
every single day after I get it edited
and up on those directories it's been a
great week I had a good week
it's a great it's going to be a great
summer folks it really is the start to
this summer is going to be great we're
gonna have a lot of stuff to talk about
a lot of wedges to draw and they're
gonna have a lot of rakes to step on a
ton of rigs speaking of that go to
store.dtonymichaels.com at
store.thedonymichaels.com watch all the
social media channels I'll be posting as
we get new products up on the store now
rather it's letting me rate products or
the new [__] Pride products we get
them uh Miss loveseat suggested and
everyone chimed in after they made this
she made the suggestion that we put up
um Pride [__] em logo merch on the store
so we have done that so go to
store.donymichaels.com check it out
there just keep going back all weekend
we're gonna get new products as it goes
and again I'll post them on social media
as we put them on the store and get them
100 loaded for you guys uh to love and
to support us with we love the merch
because you get something in return
right like you give us some monetary
support and you get something in the
mail and she can wear and you can tell
the whole world [__] them [__] em [__]
em with your shirt or your merch your
hat you can do all sorts of things so go
to the Tony michaels.com all the links
are there
I won't be here on Monday I won't be
here Monday Gabe will be but this show
will be the same time same place have a
great weekend Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon